i don't know if anyone's gonna buy
tickets where we built these million
dollar ramp set up and we're rehearsing
an airplane hangar
with no
with no hope of not helping but we're
not sure if it's gonna be successful and
you guys came with the whole mad tv crew
we're like well maybe we
maybe there's something here yeah they
want to drive all the way out here to
shoot a comedy i remember like begging
to be in it oh it was super cool like i
got my hands and he's like
tony hawk a [ __ ] get me there
because they had jackie chan once and
they left me out of the sketch and i'll
never forgive them oh what wait really i
never told you that story damn i'm going
to tell you the story funny
can i stand yeah well you know well i
know but you did a response like you
backed up a little bit
no are you fine yeah okay sure i'm
giving you room
thank you
why am i standing i just said jackie
chan yeah oh yeah so it was pound when i
first got on mad tv
i wrote i heard that jackie chan was
doing the show and so i wrote dick
blissucci
the executive producer a letter
and i go dear mr blusuji i know i'm new
on the show and i only play
japanese people on the show
or something like that right and uh
which i'm happy to do thanks for the job
but i go you know my idol is jackie chan
i know he's gonna play the show
and i i don't even need to have a line
just put me in the back i'll be a tree i
don't give a [ __ ]
so i forgot about it a couple of months
later i'm watching the show
and i see jackie chan on the show
with everyone on this cast except me
damn you didn't even know when it taped
no oh that's oh
you couldn't have two asians on screen
though oh is that right what would you
like to say or something
you know it was back then but that's
when i pooed on his office the
blizzuchi's office yeah that's why you
put in his office jackie chan you know
what honestly it's deserved then i never
knew why you put in his office wait did
you really but i feel like that's well
deserved well i didn't poop
oh my god so ike baron holtz and nicole
parker were writing a sketch in his
office yeah and i walked in and and
they go hey bobby here's the tums and i
goes stick in your butthole just as a
joke
yeah so i grabbed and i go okay i pulled
my pants down
right i stuck the thumbs in my butthole
yeah and i bent over and they're these
two are writing and they're looking at
my bottle and my butthole is like
foaming fizzing
like a mad dog
right right
and when your butthole foams like that
right and it makes that noise your
friends watching they laugh hysterically
right i like how this is a shared
experience yeah we all know oh yeah
totally
i know yeah every time too is it
annoying it's annoying so it started
going right there laughing and then
i farted and that's what the mistake
that was bad if you stick your tums in
your butthole and you fart no no because
what happened was [ __ ] came out
and it came right and all over the floor
and with the foam and everything
and then dick lucy walked into the
office
he sees the pooh my pants you know
wait is this post jackie chan this is
after jack
right and um
but then i said well you didn't put me
in the jacket because that's no reason
to sit on my floor
oh damn i mean so i learned you learned
a valuable lesson i think you're a
trailblazer thank you thanks uh another
one another handshake there you go thank
you
have you guys ever pooed on anything
[Laughter]
you've never put on anything yeah i put
on stuff yeah
let's dig into that let's go to that
i don't want to dig into it
with tony you don't have to we don't
have to talk about it not intentionally
yeah no i don't know why i told that
story
man that was making a point i was making
a point
i met him at a sports awards show a long
time ago and
we both left it was like they did a they
did this big long tedious sports awards
thing and it was just never ending it
was a dinner too and then
and then they had this after party that
was just chaos and and we ended up both
in the hotel lobby
you and jackie me and jackie chan
and then he recognized me and i was just
so excited that we ordered a bottle of
wine and shared a bottle of wine it was
awesome yeah
yeah that's so [ __ ]
dude that's magical [ __ ] it was really
cool and he was he had his sort of
manager
dude partner white dude or no uh-huh
clearly clearly they've grown up
together i think we should try and
broker a similar thing for you and
jackie chan i feel like until you meet
jackie chan your life will never really
be in order because you're still
yearning for that and dick lesuchi you
know stole that from you so i don't know
if tony you're maybe you can be no no no
no listen listen jackie chan
listen this is back in the day when i
didn't know anybody but jackie chan is
also my idol so get it going okay i'll
get it going
well
when you're in those situations in your
head are you going
what the like how do you enjoy do you
enjoy it or are you kind of freaking out
both yeah
but you know you don't want to turn into
the chris farley super fan like you
remember when you did it
that was cool yeah yeah so it's hard not
to do that yeah so it's it's more just
trying to have normal conversations but
he ended up going into this crazy story
about
when he got a skull fracture or
something he got some crazy really
life-threatening injury i can't remember
what jumping off a moving thing just
missed the target i don't know